sometimes i love bad legal takes
especially when they come from at bad
legal takes and this one
i think came up in the context of
section 230. someone says google is a
monopoly and
therefore i guess not a private company
to which ari cohn who is generally an
excellent legal commentator chimes in
even if it was monopoly and it's not
that doesn't make it not a private
company to which the commentator
helpfully responds before you try and be
a smart look up some basic definitions
let me start you off with a public
company is one that is traded publicly
in the open market and google well look
the company went public via
initial public offering in 2004. public
no oh no so this is a horrible horrible
legal take because
admittedly there are two different
definitions of a public company one
is a public company that's owned by the
government the first amendment applies
to the government and if you are the
government the first amendment applies
then second a publicly traded company is
one that just has stock that you can
purchase on an exchange it doesn't mean
that they are owned or operated by the
government
and if you are a publicly traded private
company the first amendment does not
apply to you